there we go
uh
thanks very much uh it's really great to
be here
um
and with the addition of all these
lovely people at this uh
workshop and thanks very much to ben
for that excellent talk extremely clear
and i'm going to piggyback basically
straight off the back of it this is a
really unusual talk and it's the
opposite of ben's talk which presented
some some fantastic research with
conclusions i'm presenting
work that it's not even in progress it
hasn't started yet it's a brand new
project
and the news about this project has been
embargoed until recently so i've
literally never spoken about it
this is really
exciting and big for me
so i'm a former lawyer come critical
legal theorist working
interdisciplinarily on the question of
what the human is for law
more or less and obviously i realized i
had to address the question how the
technological upheavals that we're
facing interact with that question and
for some time i've been teaching around
some of these questions at the
university of kent
and that led to the
funding proposal for this project which
has just been funded
quite amazingly it's a seven year
fellowship so i'll be working for four
years with a budget of about 1.25
million pounds which thing about 1.5
right now so well that's a euro that's
the euro pounds worth a bit more still
anyway uh and then with a separate
budget for the last three years um the
reason i'm being particular about those
things is because part of the point of
this talk is to
um
create a potential for conversations and
involvement in the project and so
i'll talk about some practical things as
we go what i want to do is three things
reframe the challenge of adm in
administrative decisions which is the
focus of my project i want to talk about
my research design for working on
administrative decision quality in other
words what we should be doing or how we
should be working on these problems
according to me
and then finally linger at the end on
this research use of live action role
play as a really important
methodological key for my work and that
i think is a great platform for
collaborative work on these problems
so
right before i submitted my grant
proposal i published a piece called
automating authority the human and
meaningful human control autonomous
weapons
i'm going to skip through this pretty
quick because ben's covered a lot of the
salient points and some other
discussions have too i concluded that in
international law this emerging norm of
meaningful human control
offers us a human that is not a legal
concept the human has no legal status
at all instead human is a floating
signifier with huge symbolic capital
that's co-opted for political ends most
of the time in this specific context
uh i suggest that the human is offered
to us as an a priori non-technological
reflective autonomous agent with a
legitimizing or stabilizing function
and my conclusions were that this
emergence or this positivization in law
of this figure of the human at least in
this setting
uh it has three main qualities first
it's it's fundamentally contradictory
and historically significant because
what it actually does is legitimize a
new techno-economic political
arrangement while in fact diminishing
control uh in the name of the human
i suggest it's dangerous it ignores
risks and problems that ben has talked
about and it's also negligent and this
is my key point it's negligent because i
think governance should do better than
to simply offer this lazy figure of the
human and that led me to think that
scholarship should also be doing better
we should actually be working harder on
this question of can this figure of the
human serve this function in a
meaningful way or is it just
eviscerating our governance processes
and so my project is an attempt to
shift that problematic to the
administrative decision context which as
ben has said is really important and
i'll skip through this very briefly i
just want to point out a key dynamic
here so over here we've got
um some basics about the context which
we've heard a lot about through this
meeting but i wanted to point out that
how significant it is that scholars know
that that
we will not really fix these problems
just by sort of tweaking transparency
settings or something like this is not
how we're going to resolve this problem
and the scholarship is absolutely full
of people using the language of epoch
epochal change
you know radical ontological difference
like these kind of massive claims and
yet governments and here you know
there's of course lots of legislative
responses which do things in all kinds
of contexts but my interest has been in
what administrative governance is doing
about this problem and actually these
are some of the techniques that are
being used here on the right
they're all good i'm not saying they're
not good but i think they do not begin
to address the problems that scholarship
has addressed and so my project
frames that sort of question of like
what would a coherent
response to this problem look like
i think it's significant that meanwhile
outside of the legal setting or the
administrative government setting
people are talking about this they're
saying
humanity is being reconfigured like a
fundamental presupposing presuppositions
about how we work and who we are what
what is good what languages we should be
using the people know uh this and yet um
we don't see
that level of uh epochal change shifting
through into administrative law and
administrative practice which um
obviously as ben has said as i put up on
this previous slide affects all of us in
each of our lives every visa application
every tax determination is an example of
a setting where our lives can be
directly affected by these um
these techniques
so um
what i find really interesting and what
i mentioned in my automating authority
paper
is why is that that not only um you know
philosophers of technology and ethicists
and it's not only these people who see
this problem it's lawyers too lawyers
know
a judge who's working with me on this
project um has published you know an
article so desperate was he to go on
record saying how deeply problematic and
dangerous this situation is and yet
there's something about the kind of
legal discourse
that constrains the sort of response
that we can
offer not only that but i think
administrative law is uniquely
constrained
it's a very high stakes field every
decision directly affects somebody so we
can't experiment very much with it
it's deceptively important to political
health as a stabilizing kind of function
administrative decisions have been the
site of intense work historically
speaking at technical historical
imaginary philosophical theoretical and
practical ethical levels
what you are referring to as
administrative law
and losing us
in your talk okay if you could just
quickly say all i mean by ministry law
is the law that regulates the kinds of
decisions that we've been talking about
that's all we need to to know so the law
that says how they should be taken which
is the law of good decisions at the
moment well it's not even law it's
policy about what good decisions look
like how we should take decisions and
then the law that governs how we can
review those when they're termed to be
out of line and so that's where i have
to gloss over with that left column
which talks about the fundamental we
really don't need to know any ministry
of law to know what i'm working on um
what we do need to know is that the key
principles of that administrative law
are the ones that people acknowledge are
in deep fundamental conflict with the
way that ai and machine learning
environmentally work
but my point is that the administrative
state has been a key site of human
political endeavor to institute a set of
values and norms that
have been worked on in very intense and
very deliberate and very overt ways and
what i see now is that that sort of work
is not being done we're not adequately
taking account of the way in which we
need to rethink these processes and
their fundamental normative uh
foundations
so
what my project does is
lightly but fairly radically reframe the
question of how we can evaluate the way
in which decisions are um are understood
as being taken by humans in government
with or without the involvement of
machine learning
so what i've done is displace the tasks
to a different kind of level of analysis
it's not that radical to the extent that
all i'm doing is saying we need a new
vision and practice of good decisions
for a new technosocial
media ecology
so
the public lawyers in the room which is
maybe one or two will know that good
decisions is also itself a kind of
technical language and that has been
addressed in a certain way
typically through very human terms of
what kinds of things you have to look at
what kinds of reasoning how careful you
need to look don't exceed your power all
these kinds of practical guides but
interestingly these have not been
updated despite the sort of raft of
other kinds of legislation that have
emerged with the rise of machine
learning
so my proposal is that what we need to
do given the sort of kinds of
ontological work and identification that
the people we've just been looking at as
sort of with this radical diagnosis are
talking about is we need to take more
seriously the evolution not just of law
which is something people talk about how
is law evolving or how is legal
reasoning evolving because of of the the
input of these kinds of new modes of
reasoning through machine learning but
rather to think about the whole
technical milieu our whole life world
and not only that but to take seriously
how evaluative principles belong with a
particular media world or life world
so
that's extraordinarily difficult to do
however and
of course there's no shortage of
theorization about these questions um
there's no shortage of sort of new norms
or new rights or new kinds of principles
that people are proposing
and there is also also some practical
change but what my project suggests is
that we need a a
coordinated in human engineering effort
to turn three keys at once so that there
needs to be some sort of
solid theorization
of this
problem of decision making
that isn't just somebody's theory
concocted from behind their desk but
actually resonates with how a social and
technosocial world understands what's
happening when decisions get made
i think that needs to go hand in hand
with a coherent or integrated set of
normative principles or or inculcated
values that are institutionalized
along with compatible practical change
so concrete processes protocols and
decision support systems
um so
really uh
this sort of task of turning these three
keys i think is a very difficult one
and the problem that i sweated over in
devising my project was to think about
how how would you do that or
i actually ended up scaling back the
question to be not how do i do that but
how
should people be working in a way that
this might happen really that's the
question so how do you work on a problem
like this in a deeply uh holistic way
and the answer i came up with was this
research design
um and so
it's
sort of perhaps slightly daunting but
i'll break it down for you just a bit
so
i start with a theorization of what
decisions are in techno-social ecologies
which is not a question
that those that the theoretical frames
that are working in this area are
particularly looking at so we're going
to do some original work there
we're going to integrate that with
normative theory thinking about how
existing ways of thinking and reason
public doctrines of public reason
decision making work and filter that
through
concrete questions of doctrine and
practice
those will be tested through this
live-action role play mechanism through
which which i'll talk about in a moment
mutually informing each step of the
project culminating in an empirical
study of a real decision-making process
in a multi-sided ethnography so the full
scale how
how is the decision system conceived
designed implemented
evaluated etc
culminating in a realistic re-envisaging
of that decision-making process
in this new sort of pre-figured way
through a live-action role play
um i'm going to had some more
information on each of the sub-projects
that's not particularly important except
to note that over here i've got
collaborators and to note that this work
is fundamentally collaborative this is
not going to be produced from behind
a desk this is the second project
thinking about how how we can reconcile
human and cybernetic normativities
uh and think about technosocial
evolution in terms of law
uh here we have the
discovery of best practices for the
administrative design
including jake golden fine and some
other names the only thing i want to
note here you may know some of these
people if you work in this field
uh the only other thing i want to note
is i'm working with supreme court judges
federal court judges
and have a mutual consultative role with
the law commission in the uk so this is
the channels are open to make this a
reality whatever we come up with after
seven years has stands a high chance of
affecting the way in which reform has
been conducted the law commission is
looking at this problem right now and
i'm in dialogue with them
so uh multi-sided ethnography the only
thing i wanted to conclude on here and i
know this is a lot but um i wanted to
talk briefly about live action role play
i'm working with specialists from the uk
and italy on live action role play
and these are sort of large
collaborative events where we imagine a
process for decision making and
we set it up and we do it we play it so
people i'm talking about members of the
public academics from across the
different disciplines government
employees we will be
conducting a series of three live-action
role plays across seven years and i see
this is a really appropriate way to
develop new normativities through this
kind of iterative process
uh and i'm working in combination with
large public institutions that that do
this kind of like creative ai arts ai
kind of experimentation
serpentine galleries and their labs i
want to draw attention to the creative
ai lab who will be working with and then
a bunch of collaborators from across the
whole project
and indeed other people who want to get
involved as the project unfolds all i've
got here are just some of the parameters
that i
know that we will be messing with as we
design these systems and play around
with them i think
i mean that's all i really have to say
knowing that this is quite a lot to take
in and of course knowing that
um
everything kind of depends on
what kind of decision you're trying to
model what you're trying to do that will
determine
for example what are the kind of
meaningful sites of participatory
deliberation coming out of these
technosocial uh philosophies of
evolution it might determine how we
think about
what how decisions are becoming
disaggregated in time so through the
work of designers ends up really being
the key site perhaps of where decisions
or how decisions are constrained
or bounded as we might say
how we define the loop of the decision
that's commonly done what kind of
interface we might need how and in
different what different ways
uh ai and humans might be interacting
through these processes
um in conclusion i would say this is an
attempt to take very seriously the
question of given these kind of
ontological changes that peter was
talking about earlier and the kinds of
need for contingency and deliberative
space that other speakers have been
talking about
how can we actually build a process for
research that enables us to work in that
way that also feeds a process a
potential process for decision making as
the administrative state seeks to reform
itself in response to this problem
uh i look forward to discussions now and
in the future if you want if this is
interesting to you and you want to know
more or get involved
thing yeah
right
we'll we'll follow that usual process so
hands up and
i i like salone's approach of like when
when i'm not you'll know that
one two
and go ahead
um yeah my question is
first thanks thanks to both of you for
uh for really fascinating papers um
and uh
um as a you know in a past life i was a
theater scholar so i'm absolutely
fascinated by the idea of larping your
way to better legislation
in some sense so i'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit more
about that because uh you know usually
trying to simulate the impact of real
life decisions by reenacting the process
of a decision leads to different
outcomes than the actual decisions right
because the circumstances are different
and people are very you know humans can
very well differentiate between
something that's simulated and something
that's that's real right so what are
your thoughts about how to implement
that uh practically yeah great do you
want to take multiple questions
i'm going to need my notepad
okay so this is this is primarily i
guess a question for connell but it's
it's
it's not intended to be um a challenge
and it actually relates to what ben is
talking about as well and in
uh
well so i guess i guess you know i i i
know it's a shorthand and it's it's a
it's a unity it's sort of referring to
unity or something that's very
disaggregated and fragmented but when we
use the word state then we talk about
like administrative
decisions
you know that's a kind of um in a way
like almost an outmoded
um frame of reference in itself
and i think you know one of the
interesting things that goes on in a lot
of the discourse
commercial discourse um as well as the
political discourse and here i'm just
thinking of uh mr dominic cummings who
for anyone who doesn't know this was
boris johnson's kind of like
pseudo-intellectual
um scientific guy who wanted to
literally sort of turned the entire uk
government into a kind of
algorithmically governed control station
you know
and against that kind of imaginary where
the state is disaggregated into this
kind of like um
real-time simulation of the world you
have something like what ben i think i
take you to be suggesting which is
actually this is an opportunity to think
about disaggregation of democratic power
right and a reimagination of the
political that doesn't refer to the old
administrative state
and i just wonder if ben is it's a
question like if i picked you up that
correctly and conall
is that just you're just using the state
as a shorthand i mean are we kind of
thinking like okay maybe the state is
the thing that is both being attacked
from all sides in this in this kind of
project yeah
all right if anybody ha sees a
microphone
near them
then
one has
mysteriously gone listen okay
yeah we can do that yeah
um thanks fabian this is a really great
question um
and so i think yeah you have to
acknowledge when you're using live
action role play you're using an
aerialist mode right you're not
trying to determine real outcomes
there's other work
uh now looking at for example how real
citizens
feel when they know that decisions have
had you know or an automated aspect to
them
and that isn't what i'm trying to test
what i'm looking for are kind of
sites of not of new kind of normative
value within these kinds of apparatuses
and the idea is that the
we're testing multiple things throughout
that process and it's an iterative
process so the first in fact the larps
kind of increase in realism as they go
on
and it's very important to me not to
um
begin by saying oh that isn't real or
that isn't realistic or that isn't a
real legal criterion or what normative
values are you trying to introduce you
know those are things that reviewers of
my project asked about sort of very
grumpily
and the answer is we we cannot start
there we know that our existing
frameworks aren't really working we need
to start somewhere else and so this is
the point of studying in these
ecological philosophies
um and so the first lab for example is
super unrealistic i'm doing basically a
crowd-sourced drone strike right
paradigm so participatory you know in a
very dystopian mode it'll be a two-hour
game or three-hour game
with lap geniuses chaos league in italy
and you know people will be able to see
what would it be like to have to take
the decision to kill
in in a cohort of anonymous online
people of who you're interacting with
and interacting with ai and real-time
signals intelligence and like what would
that actually be like and so you can see
what i mean the aim is to look at the
technical interface
problems more so than solutions or real
outcomes and then that'll be iterated
across different laps you know as i go
which we can talk about other times but
i think it's important to know i'm
working on normative imaginaries to
start with yeah i'm not working on
what would the outcome be if we tweaked
this value in this you know if we back
propagated in a certain way here that's
all going to be part of it but in a very
loose way
that's right suspension i just believe
feeling required for a measurable
outcome even if it's a speculative
scenario but we can talk about this uh
yeah okay yeah i'm not sure i understand
the question but
i think um about the safety i think um
i'm forgetting about the steak for a
moment strategically right to do that
thing of like let's really build let's
really start somewhere else and kind of
build it and so i'm very influenced by
bernie stiegler's philosophy who didn't
get a chance to talk about
but i'm looking at it like a constructed
situation so you construct the decision
first and then see how that like how
would the state figure once
once we once we think we know what
decisions would be
and what good decisions might look like
within a technic you know in an
imminently technosocial value system
um yeah that would be my answer
mike was discovered
um
yeah i mean i think
i think you could sort of decide whether
you know maybe open question how much
you want to incorporate the types of
uh institutional oversight mechanisms
into the administrative state but i
don't i think it's actually quite
concordant with many of the
administrative state mechanisms that are
already in place i mean something like
notice and
uh sort of like public comments on
proposed rule changes in the u.s is an
example of a form of democratic input
over sort of these broader decisions you
can envision like part of my sort of
stage one of agency review could be a
version of that where the rule would be
we're going to implement this algorithm
to you know inform sentencing decisions
and let's have public comment about that
so really shifting those decisions
upstream in a more stringent way and i
think that actually fits in with quite a
bit of what the administrative state
mechanisms already exist for and that's
probably an easier path
forward than sort of abandoning that
paradigm
and i think sort of an additional sort
of response to fabian's question from me
is because i've you know much of my the
prior work i was talking about was
experimental research with lay people
making these types of decisions and sort
of the obvious response was like you're
not working with judges like what does
this mean and i think there's always the
challenge with experimental work of both
recognizing that it's not the field
there's always issues of ecological
validity but also there are insights you
can get from experimental work or these
sorts of like simulated role play that
are different than what you could get in
practice and also allow you to play with
these mechanisms in a low stakes way
right so if we can build our scientific
understanding without having to put
these systems into practice that's a lot
of value and then the
always the question with experimental
work is figuring out what translates
into the real world and what doesn't but
i think there's a lot of
value with that type of humility in
bringing that knowledge uh to bear
all right so i have a few questions on
tap but i would like to interject a
question
um first to connell i still don't i
still want you to say the difference
between administrative law and law
like why do you keep putting that word
administrative in front and i feel like
it's a coded thing that half people in
this room
know the answer to and the other half of
us
don't so that's my question and then to
ben
such a clear like you laid this out so
nice and clearly um
i think what i took away is that when
you
um
your idea is to kind of shift the burden
of proof
on the interjection
not to say
all right we're going to interject
an algorithm now what we're going to do
but rather
let the
institutional
leaders
first say you've got to prove to me
why the algorithm
is
is needed is it efficiency is it
capacity
what is it but then like is there
possibility of a recursiveness happening
like
then the
way the answer is well we'll put it in
to be more efficient but we'll always
like have a human in the loop
what's to stop that little gremlin
coming back
so that's the whole question
you don't have to address the final
[ __ ] but it was really
the tail end
and then
like what i could do is take a few more
questions so
um maybe it's
ben and sonia and then
[Music]
well i can't wait because i'm more like
want to make a connection i really
enjoyed the session actually i was also
on zoom for the morning session which i
also enjoyed so i really want to make a
connection of the issues you talked
about by human to loop to upstream
before the algorithm being deployed
right that's where i come from i'm a
data scientist machine learner or
statistician
and they're actually
myself by collaboratively advocating
this making things transparent
and we make so many human judgment calls
definitely including human biases
and i i wonder whether there's capacity
for you to even go upstream to the
development algorithm i think that'll
make it more integrated system
and some of what both of you said i
think are very relevant there too
so i just want to make the connection
thank you
oh okay
and then we have some others that
yeah thanks for these these questions i
think um yeah i think we can continue to
sort of shift upstream uh like helen how
you sort of framed it as yeah really i
really think about it in terms of
shifting the burden of proof away from
we'll put in the system and then we'll
add a corrective to why are we putting
the system in place at all and i think
as part of that that would involve i
didn't get into this too much but
actually having much more of that review
process also includes some discussion of
you know if to the extent we're going to
incorporate human algorithm
collaboration is there evidence that
that works right so the burden of proof
should be that we are skeptical that
human oversight or human collaboration
with ai can solve those problems to
actually the default assumption should
be that human oversight doesn't work and
to the extent that we it does work then
we can actually do that and that goes to
bin's question where i think a lot of
the insights for this work also i think
do go upstream into the development
process and that's sort of where that
algorithm and the loop idea comes from
is that we actually shouldn't be just
saying we're going to design a model for
maximal accuracy and then put it in and
do human in the loop we should be
designing for improving human decision
making not accuracy and i think uh
shannon's work from yesterday morning on
unremarkable ai is a really good example
of that that often the the algorithm
that's going to best improve human
decision making is actually quite
different than the algorithm that is
optimal just on purely sort of
statistical measures so we actually need
to be shifting what we're even designing
for from a development perspective yeah
yeah
yeah i totally agree i mean so the
second second lap that we're going to be
doing my project at the moment looks
like it will be larping
the collaborative development of the
whole the decision system right so what
would it look like if a government
agency knows now we need to make a
certain kind of decision this is going
to be coming or we want to reform a
decision process
who decides how that works at the moment
people don't even really know and it
happens very ad hoc very in department
there's no centralized best practice
there's nothing so i want to go
completely in the other direction say
let's go as far upstream as we can and
get everyone who might be vaguely
affected
involved right and say how do we
co-design this system
we can do live building live coding like
building you can have sessions like i
actually want to do this it won't be
real but that's what i want to do the
interactions will be real the coding
will be real i want to go way upstream
being i think you're absolutely right
that's super important
yeah absolutely
um
should we answer in this question
yeah uh well
i mean this is yeah okay so i mean i
don't want to go too long about this but
it's a big thing i mean
the first thing is there's a huge trend
in my field away from talking about law
law as this capital l law
because all law is not the same
law is not some sort of
it's seen as a hangover of this kind of
like theological sense of law there's a
sort of grand thing called law and we
all interact with law there's a huge
trend in the kind of theoretical frames
i'm working with to say
if we do away with that notion we think
about
more detailed analytics like control or
power or
project production of subjectivities
through technical means it gives us more
agency and how we work on it right so
this is a sort of major movement that i
guess i seem to have endorsed but more
generally i think i'm
well secondly and different branches of
law work very differently and i don't
want to talk about all kinds of law the
way
uh i've been teaching about sentencing
judging with my students it's completely
different it just has nothing to do i
think
with how administrative decision making
works they're just it's just a very
different process
it's not judges there's no judicial
society
which helps to regulate how judges
navigate these tools
there's none of that it's it's a very
different subject who's making these
administrative decisions as a bureaucrat
um
just really briefly fascinatingly you
can find literature from the 40s and 50s
saying or this administrative
decision-making should be automated
right it's a core value of the
administrative state that that's the
sign of rationality the more you can
remove the individual subject from it
and suck the discretion out of it the
better so that makes admin law very
specific context for thinking about what
ai is doing in that context right and
how interplays with value and what we
want out of the decision yeah so i'll
leave that there all right thanks
sonia peter and what is your name jason
okay
okay so you can hear so um
actually
right at the end when you mention power
that's what's really missing in both of
your talks it's creation and
subjectivity so from the fecalian
perspective
and and i really buy his from the
dungeon to the panopticon to the
neoliberal subject to now i take it
we're in this sort of an algorithmic
form of governance that's sort of maybe
another step
and what both of your presentations it
felt more like if we think of hobbs or
um
bentham or
gary becker
i felt that you're more in the role of
those guys trying to just come up with
this new thing and i'm completely
missing where jake that first day when
we're talking about power i i'm it seems
so like there's no power there's no i
don't know i just sort of
sort of baffled you're morally just for
doing this administrative which is
bavarian by the way i mean it just goes
back to weber that the state is just
going to be doing this sanitized thing
of governance and i just felt that
you're part of that program and the way
that both of you were presenting your
analysis so if you could reflect on that
and
thank you thank you
maybe i'll start i mean
oh sorry okay
sorry it's such a big question i thought
we should get started early
maybe yeah
mine is a relatively brief question for
ben i really appreciate the uh
i'm moving away from that scapegoating
of the human individual who's kind of
weighing in as the decision maker to the
ai make a good decision here no i
override it and so on
and it seemed to me like you were
suggesting that the institution take a
role in that and i was wondering what
does that really look like in practice
so i see that the move from an
individual human
oversight is good go to a group or
something like that but what would the
group be comprised of i mean who would
be involved and would that differ
depending on situation
are we talking about an ad hoc
deliberative council that's developed to
come in and
look at decisions over a period of time
is it a one-off thing i'm just wondering
sort of practically speaking what that
alternative looks like between the
individual
and institutional black box you know
[Music]
okay thank you very much uh i have two
related questions the first is for ben
and the second i think will be uh
amenable to both of your
presentations so the first is that i'm
very sympathetic to the findings that
you describe in fact they kind of
resonate with my assumptions about what
has been uh discovered through
socio-technical research
but i'm curious when we say that human
in the loop systems like don't work when
we say we've studied it and they're not
performing better um
what what is that what is the kind of
metric that we're using so you know in a
sense like it will always be surprising
you know deep mind we see is when you
add a human to the mix it's not going to
work as well as some like aggressively
optimizing algorithm but often the
normative ask is something different for
people to have an experience that they
feel like emotionally salient or where
they believe that they got to error
grievance or something like that um so
does your notion that these algorithms
don't succeed take into account the
broad set of meanings that people might
be asking for when they request humans
in the loop
and then the kind of the building upon
that i'm curious like if we were to kind
of try and rescue the idea of human in
the loop and not just think of it as
ideological wash or a kind of simplistic
implementation of some kind of technical
system what what could we say in defense
of the notion or what what might that
look like
um here's
here's a choice we've got three more
questions and i'd love to take all the
questions we could start t five minutes
late and you know what what would you
like to do i don't mind
uh yeah i'm happy to go over a few
minutes but maybe could respond to that
yes yes okay
let's do that i already think i didn't
get yesterday
sorry
um
i don't mind okay
sure i'll sort of try to respond to to
all of that
um
yeah i mean i think i sort of brushed
certainly brushed over some of those
questions of power
that
i think are absolutely sort of
structuring this idea because
what i see the human oversight paradigm
is doing is exactly creating a band-aid
over those questions of injustice and
sort of unaccountable power right so you
have organizations whether it's welfare
agencies or large tech companies or
court systems that are essentially able
to just choose to unaccountably put
these systems into place to surveil
control punish individuals
and the human oversight provides this
very superficial way of saying oh but we
are accountable we are caring about your
outcomes and so i think you know and
that sort of gets into some of the
examples of how then the power there's
that significant amount of power for say
a police chief to blame the you know a
police officer for not overriding the
facial recognition system when it's the
police chief and the technology
companies that put these systems into
place to surveil
punish and so on so i think that it's
absolutely operating as this sort of
mechanism that allows the power
uh powerful individuals and
organizations to operate uh without
accountability
um
and so i think
when
and so yeah so i mean with respect to
you know one of the the goals i i am
sort of yeah looking at how is is human
oversight actually able to address those
types of concerns around are they you
know identifying errors making the
system less biased and so on um i mean i
think there's this sort of open question
that sort of gets out of somewhat of
like a european versus american approach
to these things of how much of it is
just a dignitary harm where people want
a human to be involved as a sort of
dignitary
uh
salve and whether or not that actually
leads to better decisions i'm not that
sympathetic to the view that just
inserting a human
creates a more dignified process if the
insertion of the human is not preventing
discrimination or preventing errors and
so on um but yeah so the the various
experimental research is really looking
at
both accuracy but errors and and so on
sort of looking at the other types of
values that we might care about and even
thinking about
uh
yeah how it's warping the
decision-making process entirely and
actually shifting from say
shifting to a value where maybe a judge
is only thinking about recidivism risk
and not thinking about leniency or
sort of liberty and so on in that exact
value propositions i think that's really
what i'm thinking about
and then sort of with respect maybe i'll
let actually you go and peter we can
talk offline just to make space for
everyone
yeah i mean i agree with everything ben
just said um and so for that reason i
feel justified in also semi-answering
for ben and talking about the sort of
approach that i think we might both be
taking here and i think the reality is
the state's being reformed really
quickly under the cover of darkness this
is what angstrom calls the quiet
revolution right so
there's wonderful for creating critiques
they're already there and they're not
doing anything to stop this nothing they
have no impact
no influence even if people know about
them and approve of them they can't
voice or articulate them or act on them
there's just no way to do that
i mean it's going to sound pretentious
but at a certain point someone you know
person like me has to say what am i
doing like why am i a scholar like what
what actually are we trying to do here
um
and
you know uh
in my case particularly in ben's case
particularly
look at us you know i had to put down a
critical mantle in to some degree and
say well i actually need to help
institution shape here if i can
but it's very very different i mean my
theoretical paradigm comes from bernie
stiegler right so this has just nothing
to do with state forms it's the absolute
radical left alternative to state forms
it's saying how do we keep the future
not future open how do we
deprolitarianize
how do we give people the capacity
to the right to work on their own
political determination like that's what
this is about and this is what this ai
problem is giving us to think about
how do we keep and it's not i agree with
ben it's you can't just say he's a flesh
and blood thing called a human let's put
it here i mean this is just not touching
the problem it's not touching the
network that's actually working yeah
so it's about for stiegler and for me
and for bento i think
it's about what other analytics can we
use to carve this problem up and get
different points of entry what other
evaluative languages do touch yeah this
this the qualitative nature of these
arrangements
for code it's important i mean
specifically it's important and i know
and i'm i'm fearing the day but the day
will come when this my project is
established enough that people start
critiquing it and that's great you know
it's great but i wanted to come out of
the practice i want people to be
laughing together saying here's a system
and i want the people doing it to say
this i have a problem with this system
right the critique has to come from for
me within the process in which
everyone's empowered to participate
[Music]
taken as a comment for connell um just a
little anecdote from sort of the history
of ai in which there is actually a
precedent for simulated role players
method
that starts at the very roots of ai the
1956 dartmouth conference um on ai where
herb simon and alan newell are putting
forward
what's considered the very first ai
logic theorist which if you're not
familiar it's a program designed to
prove the mathematical theorems of
bertrand russell and alfred north
whitehead's principal mathematica
and this is sort of a little tidbit from
history is that herb simon used his own
family his children and his wife and
grad students to physically act out the
program to see if it would work so they
wrote individual rules or sub-routines
um and components of memory of the
program onto index cards and they signed
each uh in an x-card to each person and
then the participants then physically
executed the sub-routine
and provided all provided the contents
of memory when called upon um which
which is like super fascinating insofar
as that this is like a really innovative
and experimental form of research that
also has can be drawn back into like the
very history of the birth of the field
itself
and one thing to sort of consider i
suppose is that i've researched and
looked at that in the context of uh
gendered histories of ai and whose labor
counts like who is an inventor at that
moment
and it's like you venerate alan newell
and
herb simon but his wife and family
whatever they're like not part of it um
and it also uh the ways in which there's
like fundamentally like embodied ways of
knowing and knowledge making at the very
beginning and yet this is all part of a
history of symbolic ai which apparently
has nothing to do with like the body and
it's all abstract
um so uh just uh just a sort of a
a huge uh shout out to university of
kent because that's my alma mater so yes
it's rare to see people from there um
yeah
anyway so um the uh one thing that i
sort of think is super super valuable
about your research call is the
ethnographic side of things which is
like a huge gap right like we have all
these like things about like these these
these should be the models it's the data
that should be used and then we have
like legal theoreticians who say you
know these are the normative things we
should think about but we never really
have anything about like the people who
actually like are involved in these
things and what sort of things they take
into account
and that sort of really answers like a
very uh deep question about it and the
other thing is sort of like a little um
sort of uh reference to the
i think you mentioned in the slides
evolutionary approach so that's my sort
of one concern
uh
it's it's sort of clear that the dust in
this area hasn't settled at all at all
right it's it's not being sort of and
the way i think about like legal
decision making like from a theory
theoretical perspective or like what how
rules emerge is that there's a lot of
factual situations that keep repeating
right and then we can abstract them away
to a higher level right
whether in a decision or a rule right
and sort of
imposing or imposing is a is a powerful
word but sort of having this theoretical
view of you know what a quality decision
is
could it be like crystallizing like
something that's kind of not yet formed
if that makes sense um but yeah thank
you
thank you
i'm gonna have a lot to discuss
including your
home universities
um thank you both those were really
wonderful interesting papers and there's
too much to say about both of them
um yeah one point was just for connell i
wanted to talk a bit more yesterday but
in french work factors they do a lot of
laughing or like a lot of these sort of
like situated simulator simulations in
the workplace and stuff that's kind of
an interesting tradition you might i
think that's a great
methodology and i don't know there's
just sort of a vein of research there
you might be interested in um
but then you know otherwise um i mean i
that was great uh i guess the
interesting thing for me is you know the
idea of the human in the loop is
providing the false sense of security
you know like that's and that's the
danger and i agree you know that's
always like uh the question of anxiety
and diminution of anxiety is always kind
of like a problem you know but um surely
i mean i guess this is bouncing off
sonia's point really you know there
seems to be like kind of a
knee over babaria and sort of
institutionalism that's kind of
resurgent at the moment um and i
disagree like my boss mark he's kind of
into this and like frank pasquale like i
think you know and i and it's it's
interesting to me because as far as i
can tell i'm not a political scientist
but you know there's never been a more
significant crisis of the institution uh
at least in america than there is today
you know um and in australia similarly i
don't know there's lots of research on
you know we always we love to have a
royal commission we're always having
royal commissions into things and they
never like do anything you know like so
this is what i worry about you know like
there's a kind of false sense of
security i agree it's like okay human
just ticks the box and it's fine
but there's a broader false sense of
security perhaps in in terms of kind of
like um
outline you know the
you know kind of what's the word i don't
know uh putting the question of
political within like this sort of frame
of the institution itself
you know what i mean i think this is
kind of an unfair question you know but
you were saying like you think this is
kind of like
what the model you're proposing is more
or less congruent with like current kind
of legislative capacities and so forth
so i don't know i just want to really
thought on that you know like is that a
danger as you foresee it
how do we kind of
you know and i and i take the point
about well you know yeah obviously yes
we also need to worry the human being
outdated but you know the leviathan you
know and all these these are all
outdated problems as well right the
state you know
so i don't know just your thoughts there
i'd be interested to hear
okay
so you
thank you very much to everybody
fantastic questions
great provocations and
cuiti
and we'll risk